[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNIE MA-WEAVER: So
welcome, everyone,
to our Distributed Ledger
Technology Partnerships talk.
My name is Annie
Ma-Weaver, and I
manage technology partnerships
for Google Cloud, focused
on our priority verticals,
including financial services.
So Google Cloud--
public cloud in general,
and then Google
Cloud in specific--
is a really good fit for
financial services because
of the specific pain
points of that industry--
and also, the pain
point of legacy IT,
which plagues all enterprises.
I'm not going to insult you
by reading from my slide.
But instead, I'm going to
speak over it, because I
think that's just a
helpful way to compliment
and illustrate things.
Over the last year,
year and a half,
we've seen a lot of momentum
in financial services
with customers and partners.
And over the next
couple of days at Next,
I wanted to highlight some
of those financial services,
customer, and partner sessions
where you could really hear
about it straight from them.
I have not listed sessions
that have already happened,
because we have not
invented time travel yet.
So Distributed Ledger
Technology, or DLT,
is relevant to more
than financial services.
As I've been talking with
customers and partners,
we've heard about use cases
across multiple verticals.
And I'm really excited
about the potential
of these applications.
But many of them, as
you know, are nascent.
And we want to be the public
cloud upon which developers
build these use cases and figure
out which of them are really
the ones that are
meant to scale and are
meant to be widely adopted.
The question I get often is, why
are companies looking at DLT?
And there are a lot of potential
benefits around costs, trust,
and security.
But many of them are
still potential ones.
And that's where I think
Google Cloud can help.
We can be a platform upon
which you can take your ideas,
and you can bring
them to fruition.
And then these potential
benefits can be realized.
So I'm excited to
announce, and as we also
announced in a blog
post yesterday,
that you can now develop DLT
solutions on Google Cloud.
You can do them in a DIY
fashion with our open-source
integrations, with two
leading DLT platforms--
Hyperledger and Ethereum.
Or if you need more advice
and help through the process,
you can work with our partners,
Digital Asset and BlockApps,
who will soon be speaking to
you more about what they do
and how they're working with us.
So to summarize, we
have both DIY and also
proprietary partnerships
that enable you to build
DLT applications on GCP.
These will be available
through the Cloud Launcher
Market, which we're now
re-branding as Marketplace.
So now I'm really excited to
invite onto the stage Blythe
Masters, CEO of
Digital Asset, who
will tell you more about
this incredible company
and how they're working
with Google Cloud.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Annie.
And hello, everyone.
It's a great
pleasure to be here.
As you heard, I'm
Blythe Masters,
and I am the CEO
of Digital Asset,
a new partner of Google Cloud.
I'm also a 27-year
veteran of JP Morgan
and the former CFO of its
global investment bank.
And back in 2015, I came across
a nascent team of developers,
academic cryptographers,
and even former traders,
and one former tank commander--
who had an extreme drive
and technology vision,
whose implications--
if I'm really honest--
neither they nor even I
truly understood at the time.
So what made me lose my mind
one day back in 2015, given
my background, to go sign
up for a microscopic startup
in the tech space with no
technology background--
I'm a business person
by background--
in what was literally a
five-person team plus a dog?
The answer lies in a
big idea, an idea that's
big enough to have material,
financial implications,
and certainly,
easily, big enough
to make a big career better.
The idea, of course,
was blockchain.
Back in 2015, everyone
thought that blockchain
was all about cryptocurrencies.
And actually, some of you
may be forgiven for still
feeling that way today.
But the reality
is the blockchain
is a lot bigger than
cryptocurrencies.
And the applications
go far and wide.
So here, three and
a half or so years
later, is the vision of
our company, Digital Asset.
Simply put, we believe
that blockchain offers
the opportunity to unleash
the kind of furiously-paced
innovation that the tech
industry has become accustomed
to over the past
10 years, and yet,
which has been notably absent
from financial services
and other giant
enterprise sectors--
from health care to
govtech and beyond.
It will revolutionize
the processing
of every asset, every
transaction, every workflow,
across and within every
business and different companies
in the world.
It's not a small vision.
Now, to understand this, just
with any great technology
solution, you need to understand
what is the problem that
is being solved.
15 years ago, if
you had predicted
that we would see the
advent of self-driving cars
more quickly than we
would discover the ability
to sell an equity and
get your cash for that
in less than two days,
or that even you'd
have the simple privilege
of walking from one doctor's
office to the next and
expecting your medical records
and identity to
travel with you, you
would have been declared insane.
But the reality is that we got
the self-driving car first.
How on Earth could
that be the case?
Well, the answer lies in
something as banal and mundane
as data architecture.
It turns out that
enterprise infrastructure,
from financial services
to health and beyond,
has been stymied by what
we call silo-ization.
Why?
Because businesses can't
securely trust, or could not
until now, their ability
to share and process data
without compromising
their responsibility
for their books and records and
confidentiality and privacy.
Now, what silos lead to
is unnecessary duplication
of records, error-prone
updates, asymmetric information,
expensive and
time-consuming breaks--
and literally, in
financial services
alone, tens of billions
of dollars a year
in a completely zero-value-added
effort of reconciling-- that
means ticking and
tying records that
are different that should,
in fact, be the same simply
because they didn't share
a common or golden source
of record.
It was my exposure
over almost 30 years,
in the bowels of the
financial services industry,
to the understanding
of the sheer scale
of the cost, the waste, the
inefficiency, and ultimately
the risk associated
with this that
led me to believe
all-in in blockchain
and to move to Digital Asset.
Blockchain, or as it has
become known as DLT--
Distributed Ledger Technology--
will change all of this.
Simply put, it's a new form of
secure database architecture
that offers businesses,
enterprise, for the first time
certainty of shared,
real-time identical records,
synchronized processing,
programmable, automatable
assets and associated workflows,
without loss of privacy
or confidentiality,
and without continuing
to have responsibility for being
able to independently validate
your own books and records.
Just as the internet
unleashed and liberated
the free flow of
information 20 years ago
and changed
everything, blockchain
is going to liberate
the processing of value,
saving hundreds of billions
of dollars of cost,
and unleashing innovation.
To hear more about
how this will happen,
I'll introduce you to
two of my colleagues--
our CTO, Shaul Kfir,
and our chief marketing
officer, Dan O'Prey.
[APPLAUSE]
SHAUL KFIR: Thank you, Blythe.
So what do we mean
when we say, unleashing
web-based innovation?
That's a very tall
order to fill.
And we're being
hosted here by Google,
a company who has really
been at that forefront
of web-based innovation.
And we've been hearing
for the past few days
about amazing infrastructure
or mutualized infrastructure,
things like Bazel and Kubernetes
and the continuous integration
and continuous deployment
pipelines that Google has.
And what those mutualized
infrastructures have done,
they have really optimized
for rate of change,
for introducing a
high rate of change
and enabling developers to
ship fast, ship high quality,
and ship efficiently
to their customers
new functionality with
very quick iteration times.
Now, we don't have that
today in the domain
of cross-enterprise
business dealings.
When we look at the largest
enterprises, and networks
across enterprises, of finance,
health care, government,
developers don't have
that same agility
that they have
within one company.
When I came out of low-level
development doing cryptography,
and x86 architecture, and
wanting to launch a business,
I had to read a few tutorials,
to read a few books--
and very quickly learning
things like Rails and Angular
and cloud APIs.
I was able, within
a matter of weeks,
to go and deploy a new business.
So that really blew my mind,
how fast you can be efficient.
And that doesn't exist when you
look at how things are working
today across enterprises.
And that's what we want to
bring through having mutualized
infrastructure, having
one infrastructure that's
deployed that takes care
of all of the heavy lifting
and allows the developers to
think about the business flows
that they're developing.
And we ask ourselves everyday,
what kind of innovation,
what kind of
acceleration can we do,
if the best and brightest
college grads of tomorrow
will be able to
do a pull request,
or be able to launch their
business deeply integrated,
from the start, into those
networks that are already
deployed across these
large enterprises?
And if they won't have to
think about deploying software
for one enterprise in a
silo, for one company,
we can now start thinking
about the broad picture,
about what it looks to do
cross-enterprise workflows.
So there's a ton of buzz
and hype around blockchain.
And the question is,
what is it that's
unique about this offering,
about the Digital Asset, SDK,
and platform, and about this
joint offering with Google
Cloud that's going to
enable what we're saying,
enable unleashing
web-based innovation?
DANIEL O'PREY: So what does
that mean for your business?
So DAML, the Digital
Asset Modeling Language,
is a new,
small-contract language
developed by Digital
Asset to, as Shaul said,
abstract away the
underlying infrastructure.
So you don't need to worry
about the cryptography,
or the distribution, or
notifications, or privacy.
You just focus on the
business of your business.
What drives value
to your customers?
And let the language
and the platform
take care of everything
behind the scenes.
In addition to that,
we announced yesterday
that DAML platform as a
service on Google Cloud--
similarly, just lets you
focus on the application,
build something
that delivers value,
do not worry about
configuring the platform--
configuring the network,
deploying the software,
and the underlying
infrastructure.
So together, this
enables rapid prototyping
for your business,
shorter time to market,
building distributed
ledger applications that
can deliver value faster and
sooner than otherwise possible,
and enabling you to be
more agile to changing
customer demands, regulatory
requirements, or market forces.
SHAUL KFIR: So you've all
heard about public blockchains.
And in public blockchains,
what those have achieved--
essentially getting
data integrity
across a large-scale
deployment, or getting consensus
over data across a
large group of entities,
be it people or companies,
and synchronizing those views.
And that is a huge achievement.
What most public blockchains
don't deal with very well
is data confidentiality.
We get the data integrity.
We get that synchronized
view, but everyone
gets that same view.
And there are varying
degrees of confidentiality.
Some do get it right.
But what they struggle
dealing with is very complex,
or generic workflows--
the types of workflows
we have in most large
enterprises today.
Now, don't get me wrong.
This is a huge thing,
and it's a great solution
to a specific set of problems.
But it's for that
specific set of problems.
What we did at
Digital Asset-- when
we started, we were a group
of cryptocurrency enthusiastic
developers, and
we said, how do we
take the same inspiration, or
the same types of solutions,
and apply it to a
different domain,
to the domain of large
cross-enterprise workflows?
Now, in the private
distributed-ledger space,
we see a lot of attempts
to achieve confidentiality
by really siloing data or using
techniques such as encryption,
zero-knowledge proofs,
or overlay networks
on top of a base network to
compartmentalize the data.
What most of those solutions
do is they trade off integrity,
or in many cases liveness.
And it's a bit too
much to dive deep.
I would love to go in
deeper in this talk,
but we talked much more
in-depth about this in our blog.
And I urge everyone
to go to DAML.com
to see how we thought
about these trade-offs
between integrity,
privacy, and liveness.
So what did we do with the
Digital Asset platform?
Through a series
since 2014 of working
with very large, potential
customers, and today customers,
we went through a series of
increasingly complex MVPs
on building a platform.
And we actually started from
those public blockchain roots,
which was my background
and my alma mater
in zero-knowledge proofs.
What we actually found out is
that the hardest problem that
needed to get solved was the
problem of data architecture,
of how do you structure your
data in a way that preserves
integrity across the distributed
system where not everyone has
all data-- so it also
preserve privacy--
and also preserves
liveness-- that the network
can't stop when you maintain
those other two properties,
the integrity and the privacy?
What we did is we
built a formal modeling
of what the data should look
like on a distributed ledger.
Then we built a domain-specific
language, again,
through a series of
MVPs and understanding,
deeper, what those use
cases are of our clients.
We built a
domain-specific language
that forces the
developer to structure
the data in such a way that
is amenable to distributed
ledgers.
On the other side, we wanted
it to be very efficient,
so it lets the developer only
think about their business use
case, about their
business workflow,
and not have to think
about the infrastructure
that they are deploying to.
What we got to is
a platform that
does real-time
reconciliation across all
of the nodes in the
network, is auditable,
analyzable, extensible.
And when you build
workflows, you
can use those common
workflows and reuse them.
So if someone builds
a library or a module,
you can then reuse
that workflow,
and again, build on top of
the shoulders of giants.
DAML, or the Digital Asset
modeling language, that's
the language that we created.
And that's the surface, or
the API, the developer sees.
They build using this
language, and that
gets deployed to pretty
complex infrastructure.
DAML is a language
that was built
bottom-up, purpose built for the
domain of distributed ledgers.
What we've seen in the
public blockchain space--
and I'm sure everyone
has heard about these--
are very public bugs that cost
stakeholders in the hundreds
of millions of dollars.
And that's simply something
we can't allow in our domain.
Some clients are
using RSDK today
to model businesses
that run daily volumes
in the trillions of dollars.
So a typical transaction
size is in the hundreds
of millions of dollars.
We can't allow a bug.
Now, those bugs that happen
in the public blockchain
space aren't because the
developers aren't skilled.
These were very, very
skilled developers.
It's because they
lacked the right tools
to build these types of
workflows in a secure manner.
There are specific
domains that are
mission critical, that
require the type of frameworks
for that.
In a prior life, I was
operating and maintaining
missile defense systems that
were protecting my life,
protecting my shipmates' lives.
And I'm extremely grateful
that none of those
were written in JavaScript.
And we took that approach.
We took that approach
of building something
that's purpose built
for this domain.
What we came up with
was DAML, and that's
a language that really abstracts
away the ledger details.
And that's the
offering that we're
making available on Google
Cloud as of yesterday.
DANIEL O'PREY: So what
can you model in DAML?
Our customers and
our partners have
built distributed
ledger applications
across many
different industries.
For example-- well
actually, when
you think about small
contracts, what they really
are at their core, when you take
away the hype and the fluff,
are shared business processes
that span across organizations.
As such, the potential for use
of DAML and small contracts
more broadly, within
commerce, is absolutely huge.
It can cover every asset,
transaction, and workflow.
So for example,
we've been working
with a large clearinghouse
in the health care space
to do straight-through
processing for claims
eligibility and
payments, to make sure
that the payer and provider and
everyone throughout that value
train sees the same
data in real time.
Medical records, as
Blythe mentioned earlier,
can be synchronized amongst
insurers, patients, doctors,
and hospitals, and selectively
reveal only the pertinent piece
of information to each
of those entities.
Our partners have been
exploring in supply chain,
pharmaceutical supply chain,
through the manufacture,
transport, and sale of
drugs, many of which
there is a large problem
with counterfeiting,
to ensure that what you receive
at the end of that supply chain
is what was produced
at the beginning.
Complex processes
can be coordinated
between e-commerce sites and
fulfillment centers and payment
providers and down to
the shipping company
to coordinate all
across the value chain,
across multiple different,
distinct legal entities.
And many more.
So we've been working with
partners on managing software
licenses, simplifying the
mortgage application process.
For insurance, reinsurance,
as well as even the issuance,
secondary market,
and redemption-- the
use of concert tickets.
So as you can see,
there's really
a broad application for DAML.
DAML can be used for any
multi-party workflow.
The largest traction
we've seen so far
has been within
financial services.
So you're going to see here a
list of some of our investors,
each of which are exploring
using DAML, building
DAML-driven applications
in their own way.
Banks, stock exchange groups,
large technology vendors,
global-systems
integrators are building
DAML-driven applications
for internal use cases
across business
lines, bilaterally
between two entities,
or even as replacements
for entire markets.
And these use cases, even
within financial services,
are very, very varied--
cash equities, repo,
collateral management.
There is a lot of
very, very complex
behind-the-scenes
processes that most of us
are blissfully
unaware of but are
vital to the functioning
of the global economy.
So these are some of the most
highly-regulated and most
demanding customers
in the world.
The goal is if we
can solve for them,
we can solve for any
commercial use case.
And I know that this
is no longer a case
of will DLT see adoption?
But when.
And that leads onto
a great case study,
one of our marquee clients--
the Australian
Securities Exchange,
the ASX, who we've been working
with for just over three years
now.
So the ASX are
doing this for real.
They're not playing
around anymore.
They have committed to take into
production a full replacement,
on national scale, our first
financial-market-infrastructure
project using a
distributed ledger.
This is not a POC.
This is not a pilot.
This is a real production build
that is going to production.
And it's not a
Greenfield application.
It's not a peripheral service.
This is an actual replacement.
At the end of this
process, they will
be switching off their
clearing-and-settlement system
for cash equities and
replacing it entirely
with the Digital Asset
platform and DAML.
So this isn't mangos
on a blockchain.
This isn't collectible kitties.
This is an application
that really matters.
If this goes down, the
Australian economy is affected.
People's pensions are affected.
And it's a real
mission-critical system.
Every single stock in Australia
will be cleared and settled
on a blockchain.
And now, we're excited
to bring that technology
to Google Cloud.
So yesterday, we were delighted
to announce that Digital Asset
and Google Cloud have
been collaborating
to bring the technology
that you've been
hearing about today to GCP.
We announced that Google Cloud
have joined the private beta
of our developer program.
And as such, their
solution architects
can explore with their
clients applications
within various
different industries,
using DAML and our technology.
We also announced the
addition of a DAML pass,
the platform as a service,
hosted on Google Cloud.
So similarly, customers can
just spin that up and quickly
and easily start
building applications.
And later this
year, Google will be
hosting a series of
developer conferences focused
around DAML.
And if you are interested in
joining, please visit DAML--
D-A-M-L-- dot-com and
registering your interest
there.
SHAUL KFIR: So as Dan said,
we're extremely excited.
For me, this is a bit of
a personal excitement.
It's paying it forward.
Just like I said,
I was mind blown
when I started web development,
seeing how fast you
can deploy a business.
I'm hoping that people will
be using this in the future.
Well, I know people will be
using this in the future,
in order to deploy their
businesses at much larger scale
and really bring that pace, that
they can do things much faster.
So I wish we had
time for a live demo.
I'm a coder, and
that's what we do.
But the next best
thing, at least,
we'll talk a little bit
about what this offering is.
So first of all, at the
top layer, what you can do
is build applications using all
of the best of the Google Cloud
infrastructure, things
like Google Cloud Functions
and TensorFlow and Spanner.
Now, I can talk for hours
about why these offerings are
so fit for purpose for
building applications
that connect into a
distributed ledger.
But just to give
a sense, many of
the workflows in the financial
world that we're working
with need data analysis,
need risk analysis,
and many types of optimization.
And those are things
that we believe
will really be able to
leverage machine learning,
and, for example,
infrastructures
such as TensorFlow,
to build very, very
efficient applications that
connect into a distributed
ledger.
Then you have the DAML SDK.
And the DAML SDK
was really built
to allow the developers to
very, very quickly reason
about a distributed application
across many companies,
and not just across
one enterprise.
And we'll talk a
little bit about that
in the next few slides.
The SDK built those
distributed applications
that get deployed
onto the DA platform.
And this is a DA platform that's
highly optimized for Google
Cloud, leveraging
infrastructures
such as the Google Kubernetes
engine and Stackdriver.
Then you can use managed
services-- either a managed
platform that's managed
by Digital Asset,
or by one of our
many channel partners
running on Google Cloud and
managed by a channel partner.
Or you can use your own
Google Cloud account
to deploy either one node
or a full network of nodes.
You can have one node that
connects into an existing
network and run it on your
own Google Cloud account.
And last, you can
automate all of this
through Orbitera,
which really gives you
a few minutes and
almost a one-click type
engagement of using the Orbitera
marketplace to quickly launch
and configure and deploy
a running network.
So on the development
side, on the IDE,
the demo-integrated
development environment
provides real-time
feedback to the developers
as they're writing code to
support efficient development
of correct smart contracts.
And what we've been
hearing from the channel
partners in their
usage of the demo
SDK is that they were
amazed at how fast they
can go from nothing to
running a POC or an MVP
on a running distributed
ledger at high scale.
We're very excited, with
the announcement yesterday,
that now Google's client
engineers and architects
have the ability-- have
joined our private beta.
And they have the ability now
to extend to their clients.
So for all of the
Google clients here
who want to hear more about
blockchain applications,
you can reach out to your
account representatives
and your client engineers.
And they'll be happy to work
and iterate on solutions.
Further than that, not
just MVPs and POCs,
we've already gone
through a process
of three years of working
with very large, very, very
complex workflows.
And even there, these
are institutions
that are very, very used to
heavy waterfall development.
And we've been receiving
amazing feedback
on that front, both
directly and through channel
partners, on the cycle
times of deploying
new features as they're
creating these workflows.
So they're used to having
very, very different stages
of deployment, building
features, testing.
And now they can really
compress those cycles, again,
into that same experience that
a developer today in a tech
company has, having
a running platform
and very quickly
developing and deploying--
going through that whole process
all the way to developing
a feature, testing it, having
it signed off by the customer,
and going into QA.
On the testing front, there's
an integrated scenario language,
which gives a full test-driven
development or behavior driven
development and unit
testing ability, which
is baked into the integrated
development environment.
There's a sandbox that's always
running in the background.
So if you make a mistake,
if you write a bug,
it's always running all of the
unit tests in the background.
And you'll get an
immediate feedback loop
of that sandbox of a
distributed environment that's
running locally on your laptop.
So you immediately
get that feedback.
And you can click
on those scenarios
and essentially actually
get debug tools,
the transaction graph
explorer in the same view.
So the developer can
see the code, the tests,
any errors in tests, and
the transaction graphics
explorer at the same time,
and have that ability
to go and debug in
one environment.
And you know that if it's
running in that environment,
you can immediately deploy to a
robust auto scaling and highly
available infrastructure.
Of course, if you build,
be it an MVP or POC,
or a large production
full stack solution,
you need the ability
to demonstrate it,
or you need the ability
to build UI components.
So we have in the SDK
auto code generation tools
that take whatever smart
contracts and business
logic that you
wrote, immediately
creates GRPC bindings so that
you can build applications
in whatever language you
want to build applications.
There is a JVM
framework if you wanted
to use R framework
in order to get
all of the high availability
and auto scaling properties out
of the box.
You get the ability to
dynamically create front ends.
So there is a graph QL back end.
And it auto
generates the schemas
for that back end and the types.
And it creates react components.
So you can immediately
get those components
and build your own UI.
And, again, the cycle times
on this are really amazing.
The speed at which
you can get everything
all the way to a front end.
And we have two or three
developers building POCs
that typically took months.
And, of course,
last but not least,
you want the ability to deploy.
And here we're not talking about
deploying something locally,
or on one machine
or two machines.
You really want to deploy.
And you want to deploy
to a robust Kubernetes
cluster that's running in,
be it on prem, private cloud,
or a public cloud.
And in the case of running
it on the Google Cloud,
running it on a very
highly optimized
Google Cloud that has
all the tools to operate
your environment.
And as of our announcement
yesterday, and very soon
we'll be making this available,
that Obetera deployment,
that makes it really
seamless to go run and start
operating that network.
DANIEL O'PREY: So we're
delighted to be collaborating
with Google Cloud to bring
in the blockchain solutions
to GCP.
To learn more about DAML--
next slide-- please
visit daml.com,
where you can request early
access to our developer
program, which includes
both access to the DAML SDK
developer preview,
and the DAML platform
as a service, which
we'll be rolling out
throughout the
course of the year.
If you'd like to see how you
can work with digital assets,
partner with us to bring
blockchain applications
to your industry,
please email us
at partners@digitalasset.com.
Shaul mentioned, reach
out to your Google account
representative and
discuss how they
can help assist you bringing
Google Cloud-based applications
to your industry.
Or come chat to
myself, Shaul, or a few
of the other members of
the digital asset team
after this session.
So thank you very much.
Thank you for having us, Annie.
And back to you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNIE MA-WEAVER: Thank
you, Dan and Shaul.
That was fantastic.
Let's give them another
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So following on
that, I'm also really
excited to introduce the
founder and CEO of another DLT
partner of ours, BlockApps.
So I'd like to welcome to
the stage Kieren James-Lubin.
[APPLAUSE]
KIEREN JAMES-LUBIN: Thank
you very much, Annie.
Great to meet everyone.
How's the volume?
Can't hear this?
Can you turn me up?
Better now?
Yeah?
Fantastic.
All right.
So I'm, as Annie noted, the
founder and CEO of BlockApps.
At BlockApps, my role has
ranged from actually writing
our core back end software,
all the way through to what
I do today, which is events
like this, interfacing
with our partners and
our customers, et cetera.
So we kicked off in 2015,
around the same time
as Digital Asset, which makes
us ancient for blockchain
companies.
And we were sort of
more of a community
first sort of company.
So we're in the
Ethereum ecosystem,
and created the first commercial
grade version of Ethereum,
which, fairly early
on, we realized
could be deployed not just
in the public blockchain
configuration, which you've
likely heard the most about,
but specifically
in the enterprise.
So we consider ourselves the
creator of the blockchain
as a service category, which
we kicked off in late 2015
with one of Google's
competitors who I won't name.
And we're very happy to help
bring blockchain as a service
to the Google Cloud
Platform today.
So we believe also we are the
first to bring a production
blockchain application online
in a Fortune 500 context.
This is with the world's largest
mining company, BHP Billiton,
in late 2016.
And through that
effort we learned a lot
about what it takes
for enterprises
to adopt blockchain technology.
And the fact that enterprise
needs are somewhat orthogonal
to what you see in the public
networks as far as, one,
performance, transaction
throughput, latency,
the complexity of the
business logic present
in the enterprise, and all the
non-functional requirements--
compliance, privacy, et cetera--
which commercial vendors like
us help our customers through,
where you don't see in
the more open source
focused public blockchain area.
So in any case, we found that
a number of other vendors
were trying to solve the
same problems in the Ethereum
ecosystem.
One way to think of
what Ethereum has done
is it's not just a
public blockchain,
but it's also a
protocol standard,
and is something of a platform.
And we're finding the
Ethereum virtual machine
and solidity to sort of be like
Java, in the sense that it was
invented for one context,
Java being invented
for embedded
systems programming.
But it's being deployed
in many other contexts
and becoming a developer-focused
kind of community standard
that enterprises
are also deploying.
So we got together with several
of our, one, large customers,
and, two, technology
companies who
wanted to see the
adoption of sort
of a Java-style
standards-based approach
to make blockchain technology
a reality in the enterprise.
So we're on the founding board
of the Enterprise Ethereum
Alliance.
And I personally chair the
Technical Steering Committee
that sets out to
define what Ethereum
means in the enterprise.
So a little bit on our platform.
So we, again, are a
platform provider.
We sit atop the Google Cloud
and on the Cloud marketplace.
And we see ourselves as
built on open standards.
So you can think of
blockchains, again,
as not just platforms,
but protocols, protocols
for communication
and transactions.
And so we implement
these protocols
and facilitate the creation
of enterprise applications
across a variety of verticals.
As far as our
platform goes, it's
sort of split into kind
of two core use cases.
One, the ledger itself.
So on the lower side
here, a virtual machine
which does transaction
processing.
Synchronization, which comprises
the peer to peer network.
And the consensus
algorithm allows everyone
to arrive at the
same shared truth.
And the database component,
which allows our customers
to query the blockchain
as they would
a traditional
relational database.
And this is all exposed through
a variety of APIs, which
do things like key management.
So customers don't have to
think about the nitty gritty
of the lifecycle of
the private keys which
encode the data that's
on the blockchain.
Querying APIs that are
built out of the box.
So when you write
a smart contract,
you'll have an API for it
that front end developers
can write user interfaces to
without any additional work.
Et cetera.
SPEAKER: Ladies and gentlemen,
in about five minutes,
we'll be starting our
next presentation.
KIEREN JAMES-LUBIN:
So let's talk
through a few use
cases that are actually
deployed in production across
a variety of our customers.
So obviously, there is a
lot of blockchain adoption
in financial services.
So that is where we
see a tremendous amount
of our business
and have designed
our platform around a
number of the requirements.
Use cases like real
time growth settlement.
So this is bank to
bank intraday transfers
so that banks can cover
their liabilities in a very
low latency situation.
KYC, consumer customer identity
management, so that customers
may decouple their personal
identity from the information
that their financial
institutions have
to streamline onboarding so
that they can consume products
across a variety of financial
institutions much more easily.
We also have a tremendous
amount of work in supply chain.
And this is across
sectors as well.
I mentioned the use case with
the world's largest mining
company, BHP Billiton.
But we're deploying
supply chain management
software in agriculture,
in commodities, et cetera.
We even have some work
in the government.
So later this year, we will
turn on a production system that
will help Departments of
Motor Vehicles track vehicle
title, electronic vehicle
title, and vehicle registrations
through their lifecycle.
And we have a lot of business
in the energy sector as well,
which is also a
strength of Google's.
Finally, we've been working with
the Google team for maybe five
to six months now.
We actually have a launch
customer for this event.
So we are happy to announce
a partnership with a company
called Money Catcha.
So Money Catcha is an
Australian-based financial
services firm that provides
two blockchain platforms
based on BlockApps Strato.
One is called Regchain.
This is a loan
management product.
And the other is
called Homechain.
So what their technology allows
their global banking customers
to do is understand
the lifecycle of loans,
and understand all the
parameters for compliance
around these loans.
So there are a lot
of data sources
to correlate when servicing
personal loans that
fit the blockchain architecture
in a fairly seamless way.
And so they've
partnered with us,
and actually already begun
to launch their application
on the Google Cloud.
So first reference
customer already here.
A little bit more
on what they do.
So their Regchain product does
risk compliance and reporting,
again, on the loan
data that we see.
And it hooks not just
into our platform,
but some of Google's
data services
that allow them to do advanced
analytics on the core data that
is in the blockchain ledger.
So finally, I want to
talk just a little bit
about the technical integration.
So we are available
on the Google Cloud
launcher, or the Google
Cloud Marketplace now.
Our platform is
very easy to use,
but scales all the way through
real enterprise production
implications.
You can see a
picture of it here.
It has a built in
blockchain explorer, tools
for live editing
smart contracts,
deploying them on the
blockchain itself.
Search.
Search across all of the data
that is in the blockchain.
And very quickly you'll
find that your teams
or your developers will be
able to go from prototyping
an application to
deploying that application,
to productionizing it.
So we're very happy to partner
with Google on this journey
to making blockchain
not just a deployed,
but at reasonable
scale reality now,
to taking it to the whole world.
So thank you very much.
Again, I'm Kieren
James-Lubin from BlockApps.
So please, one, interact
with me after the session.
Two, visit us at BlockApps.net,
or find us on the Google Cloud
Launcher Marketplace.
And three, speak to your
Google account executives,
and use our products on
Google Cloud Marketplace.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNIE MA-WEAVER: Oh.
So I have the tough
job of following
after those two fantastic
presentation sessions.
So be easy on me.
So I'm going to close
out with the open source
integrations of Hyperledger
Fabric and Ethereum.
As I mentioned at
the start, we want
to be your preferred public
cloud for testing, developing,
and launching DLT applications.
And for that, we want to
meet you where you are.
So if you need help with your
building, with your ideating,
then you've got
really great partners
in Digital Asset and BlockApps.
But if you're the
type that's more DIY,
and you want to get your hands
dirty and build from scratch
yourself, we're
also there for you.
So the first integration
that I'm happy to share
is of Hyperledger Fabric.
This was built by
a Google engineer.
It is an open source
integration of open source code.
You can start using it today
on our Google Cloud Launcher,
now called Marketplace.
And as you can see, it's
a click to deploy option.
So I'm super excited
to share this,
because it is something
that, again, you
can start using today.
We also are building an
open source integration
of Ethereum, which will also
be available on Marketplace.
But this being software
development timelines,
it was supposed to
be done by this week.
But this week slipped a little.
So it will be done,
I've been told,
by my engineer who I don't
see here, but if he's here,
I'm looking at you.
It should be done in a
few weeks, in August.
So finally, I wanted to give
a really big, hearty thank you
to all of you for coming
and hearing more about what
we're doing with DLT partners.
And also, to our DLT partners,
BlockApps and Digital Asset,
who have been so
fantastic to work with,
have really taken not just
the technology approach,
but to Shaul's point,
also our cultural approach
to development to heart, and
brought that to our cloud.
So we're so excited about this.
And as everyone has mentioned,
if you have questions,
come and find us afterwards.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]